what's going on everybody welcome to the
fourth matplotlib tutorial video in this
video we're going to be talking about
scatter plots so scatter plots real
simple type of graph generally the idea
of a scatter plot is to either show
correlation between something or
sometimes a distribution but generally
correlation or some sort of relationship
between two types of variables or at
least in our case two types because this
will be a x and y but later on down the
road when we talk about 3d scatter plots
you can actually compare three variables
at a time so that's pretty cool so like
with population ages or something what
we could do is you know maybe age to
disease or age to cancer rate or
something like that and we could compare
but in the interest of not being dismal
we'll go ahead and just use some sample
data that we make up so let's just get
rid of basically all of this information
we'll leave the X label y label title
legend show that's fine so to do scatter
it's pretty simple you just do a peel T
dot scatter and then you scatter your
X's in your Y's and you can give it a
label and we'll call this skit skat and
then we'll give it a color of Kay okay
and then what we're going to want is
some X's and Y's so we'll just say X and
then here's another well it'll just do
it simply actually x equals empty list y
equals empty list and we'll do 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 7 8 I can't type anymore so we'll
just stop at 8 and that one just put
some random variables in here BAM done
okay so you've got your X's your Y's
your scatter down here you're ready to
rumble here we go
BAM so you've got a scatter plot and
you've got um you know it basically the
little dot dot dot kind of denotes that
these this is to let you know it's a
scatter plot basically so pretty simple
stuff that's really nothing more to talk
about on a scatter plot one thing that
you can do too is you can have a marker
the marker on a scatter plot is like the
type so right now we have a an O because
it's a circle that's filled in basically
there's a whole bunch of markers so this
would be like a star for example you
can't really tell but that's a star so
it's a very small star so another thing
that you might do is comma marker size
and I believe the default has one so if
we did something like I don't know ten
we should wind up with a pretty big
marker a marker size maybe a marker
underscore size let's try that one on
let's try that one on for size oh god I
made myself laugh okay we can't get
marker size apparently so we could what
we can do is anytime you're having this
let's do scatter plot marker size our
good friend Google we come over here and
maybe it's just sighs maybe that's what
people are doing yeah so for a scatter
plot apparently you can just do s for
size so go ahead and run that again and
they did not want to make them any
bigger let me go look this size is 10
you should be able to make these like
massive marker is a star let's go back
size equals let's make it a hundred then
I will fight you there we go
so it looks like they're a lot bigger
that's crazy so they go on a different
range later on we'll talk about marker
sizes with the 3d scatter plots I'm
pretty sure have it they're called
marker size anyway so s will be your
size in this case and so like let's do
500 make it huge there we go
it's coming out of our legend here
anyway that's how you can kind of change
the size and the marker there's a whole
bunch of markers one thing that we can
do is we can like I was trying to say
before in the first video matplotlib
marker options generally what you can do
anytime you got a question because I
don't know all the matplotlib markers I
know some of them they're like stars you
can use carrot-top and that'll make a
triangle and stuff but you're never
going to
member everything that's possible and
then like with matplotlib colors there
is like a hundred of these like really
lovely they have like pinkish orange as
a color and it's like what you're not
going to remember those so what you do
is you use google right and you type it
in matplotlib marker options awesome
here's an there's a legend guy that's
not what we're looking for we're
probably looking for markers though and
then here you go you've got all your
marker types so you could have a point
it could be a pixel a circle triangle
like all this stuff okay so you have so
many options that it would move you to
go ahead and check it out and google it
and see what all your options are but
you can do like an X to color
let's do marker equals let's make it a
start and see if that works some reason
we weren't able to change the size okay
so we got some big stars and then you
can have like an X like a I just got to
do the X just because I brought it up
okay so anyway there's a bunch of marker
types and look you should look it up
just so you can get acquainted with all
the types not like I'm going to run
through tutorial going through all of
the markers so anyways that's it was
scatter plots the size of the scatter
plot marker style that kind of stuff
line graphs can also have line style and
line width we'll talk more about that as
we get there
but if you have any questions or
comments on this tutorial please free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time